persona 5 royal it's the definitive
version and the reimagining of persona 5
now you might be asking yourself if it's
worth investing or reinvesting 80 to 120
hours which is fair but it's not just
the same game with more content it gets
the royal treatment with some
fundamental story and gameplay changes
and after getting hands-on with a bit of
p5 RS new stuff in the localized version
and having followed the Japanese release
closely I'm here to tell you why p5 are
should be worth your time beneath the
mask of lavish unrelenting style is a
story about rebellion ridding the world
of authority figures widely abusing
their power it's wrapped in an RPG that
uses its soundtrack visuals and social
sim elements to connect you to its
characters and their fight for what's
right all of that of course is expected
of P 5r because it was the core of the
original but in terms of what's new well
let's start with the new crimson phantom
thief's Qasimi Yoshizawa she's a new
student at your school shooting academy
and it's pretty well known for her
talents as a gymnast from a small
snippet I played she takes a liking to
Joker judging from her acceptance of his
offer to share an umbrella to walk in
the rain and her willingness to open up
about her school life
people are often wary of me because I'm
an honor student the school is expecting
me to attain strong results in the
upcoming competitions too they even told
me I didn't have to participate in the
cleanup event but I just don't like
getting special treatment
well eventually have her fight alongside
the rest of the gang in the Metaverse
with her persona sendrayan as you see in
her awakening scene here and like
everyone else she has a fire inside that
drives her to join the cause costumey
isn't just a character added to the
roster she's directly involved in how
the main story plays out she has her own
confidante
or social linked route and there's even
an entirely new dungeon that revolves
around her she gets in between Joker and
the kechi at times and seemingly
confronts the moral quandary zuv what it
means to be a phantom thief as to the
extent to which these themes are
explored with Qasimi we'll have to wait
and see because one I haven't spoiled it
for myself and two I wouldn't spoil it
for you either one of the best parts of
persona 5 was the virtual tourism of
Tokyo taking a page out of the Yakuza
series playbook in the original game we
got
shibuya shinjuku Akihabara and more in
p5 R we have a new location within Tokyo
to hit up kiichi Choji in real life QT
GOG is a part of town with shops
restaurants and places to hang out in p5
are it's kind of like that too what
makes this place special is that there
are new group activities as you can
chill at penguins sniper a spot to shoot
pool and play darts with the squad now
why would you want to do this these
activities level up baton pass ranks
with the team adding special perks to
this clutch combat mechanic different
spots open up at night in keachi Choji -
there's a jazz club you can take your
friends - and a shrine to visit that
helps boost your stats now when it comes
to combat and exploration in the
Metaverse p5 are does some remix in
palaces have additional areas to explore
slightly changing the original layouts
Joker's new grappling hook ability is a
means to get too many of these nooks and
crannies performed as contact sensitive
actions the grappling hook will also be
a way of ambushing enemies from a
distance but it's my understanding that
it unlocks through a confidante perk
boss battles have changed slightly with
new phases fighting the first boss calm
Ishida in the demo I saw an Adam
mechanic where he summons cognitive
versions of Mishima and Shiho
I'm so sorry chica mashita I have a
rehear they affect the battle with
different attacks but you ultimately
need to inflict damage on them or , she
notes and move past this phase it didn't
change up the flow drastically but I'm
curious to see how these extra phases
are going to affect the challenge of
boss fights throughout the game
lastly the thieves den is a separate
mode that seems to be an expanded
showcase of unlockables you can decorate
the area and rewatch previous cutscenes
but I can see myself spending most of
the time playing the card game tycoon as
you can see here question and startin
again since the demo was set early in
the game I had limited access to its
roster of customization options so I'm
not entirely sure how deep it goes or
what you can get out of it quite yet as
cool as it is to see all these new
elements in action there's so much more
I'm looking forward to seeing for myself
based on what we know from the Japanese
release I can't wait to see how Qasimi
effects the dynamic throughout and what
the new palace has in store I'm excited
for the new social scenarios since there
will be additional scenes at key points
in the game there also be an additional
semester in the story to flesh out the
school life a bit more from speaking
with senior project manager Yoon Amba
who's been responsible for the series
localization there will be slight
changes to some questionable dialogue
which were said to have been carefully
considered and of course some extra
combat mechanics have me hyped up
specifically the absurdly stylist
Showtime attacks that have different
party members teaming up to lay down
heavy damage in ridiculous fashion
[Music]
it sure is nice to return to an all-time
favorite that seems to be shaken up in
some big positive ways it's not too
surprising that persona 5 royal is a
thing considering atlases pattern of
revising persona games as it did with
persona 4 golden and persona 3 fest
however it looks like persona 5 royal is
the most significant overhaul yet of
course we won't get the full picture
until the game launches on March 31st
here in the West for PlayStation 4 and
for all things persona related you can
count on me here on GameSpot
[Music]